we have a ton of legislative news to dig
into today we'll be talking about the
equality act we will be talking about
covid relief but before talking about
any of that
massive news late last night the house
of representatives
thanks to democrats mostly this was this
was democrats who voted for this
democrats in the house have passed the
massive
voting rights and anti-corruption bill
h.r
one democratic congressman ro khanna
talked to us about this when we
interviewed him last week
and this is not the first time that hr
one
has passed in the house it's the second
time that it has passed
just like the first time it passed it's
not clear how it passes the senate and
we'll talk about that but this is an
extensive bill
800 pages all sorts of of different
things contained within it
but the big items are a national system
for automatic
voter registration this is something
i've been talking about
for a decade it's something that would
dramatically increase
participation in elections and it would
ask
right now you have to opt in if you want
to register to vote the default is if
you do nothing you're not registered you
have to opt
in the system proposed in hr1
would create an automatic voter
registration system where you have to
opt
out if you don't want to be registered
to vote and why would you do that if you
don't want to vote you just wouldn't
vote
and most people would just remain
registered
the bill would require every state to
put online
options for voter registration
correcting your voter registration
canceling or designating a party
affiliation
things that in other countries are just
obvious that you have any developed
country should have these things
the bill would require at least 15
consecutive days of early voting for
federal elections
and early voting sites would have to be
open for at least 10 hours a day this
would short-circuit and preempt many of
the
state-level voter suppression tactics
that republicans have been using for a
long time
and the bill would also ban states from
restricting someone's ability to vote by
mail
and it will also require states to
prepay postage on return envelopes for
mail-in voting so it doesn't cost people
money
to vote by mail the bill would ban voter
roll
purges and also would ban the use of
non-forwardable mail
as a way to remove voters from roles
every one of these elements goes
directly at
a technique used by the right to
suppress the vote
and very interestingly hr1 establishes
a public financing of campaigns
with small donations the federal
government would do a voluntary
six to one match for candidates for
president and congress which means
every dollar a candidate raises from
small
donors the federal government would
match six times over
and the maximum small donation that
would be matched is capped at two
hundred dollars it's not funded by
taxpayer dollars
the money comes from a 4.75 fee
on criminal and civil fines fees
penalties and settlements with banks and
corporations
that do corporate malfeasance very
interesting way to structure and finance
this
and it also contains and again we can't
possibly cover
every line but there are transparency
requirements for political advertising
in hr1
it would establish nonpartisan
redistricting commissions to end
partisan gerrymandering massive issue
again we've been talking about it for a
decade it would require
presidential and vice presidential
candidates to disclose
uh 10 years of tax returns and
we know directly what that's related to
it would stop
members of congress from using taxpayer
money to settle sexual harassment or
discrimination cases
and so many other things now beautiful
bill
has passed the house how does it pass
the senate
and the answer is it doesn't unless it's
modified
significantly but maybe something can
pass
the question is why democrats control
the senate
democrats voted for this in the house
why can't democrats
pass it the answer is there are just too
many moderates
in the democratic party in the senate
and the majority is too slim
in fact it's the slimmest possible
majority the senate is 50 50 democrats
republicans
because democrats are in the white house
kamala harris becomes the tie-breaking
vote
in the senate when there is a 50-50 tie
but
this requires 60 votes to pass the
senate so in other words
i'm unsure that if it only required
50 it would pass the senate but they
need
60 votes anyway now one idea that
democrats
are thinking about is amending the
senate filibuster rules
so that any democracy reform legislation
like h.r 1
could pass with a simple majority
instead of 60 votes
now that's great if joe manchin goes for
it and that's very much
unclear if gene shaheen goes for it
i don't know if this is a bill that
jeanne shaheen
is interested in passing so right now
the situation anyway is you need 60
votes now this is an issue
on which there is almost no overlap
between democrats and republicans
we talk on this program you know some
shows love to take these black white
positions like there's no relevant
difference between democrats and
republicans
and the truth is that on some issues
there's no relevant difference between
democrats and republicans and on other
issues
they couldn't be more different
democrats at least in the house
are passing hr1 which is a massive
expansion in voting rights it would
permanently cement
many temporary expansions on the basis
of coronavirus
that's democrats at least in the house
on the other
hand as we talked about on i think it
was monday
republicans have more than 250 bills
in 43 different states to suppress
the vote to make it more difficult to
vote so
these are diametrically opposed
priorities
on these issues between democrats and
republicans democrats doing everything
they can
to increase participation in elections
republicans doing everything they can to
decrease
participation now you can take a cynical
view and say well
both sides are doing what they think is
best for them for them democrats believe
more people voting is good for democrats
republicans believe fewer people voting
is good for republicans
they are both probably correct the
difference is
one of them is actually in line with the
principles and values that this country
is based on which is
not disenfranchising people giving
people a voice
not putting not obstructing the ability
of people to participate in the
democratic process it's hard to argue
that the country is based on the values
that are exhibited by 250 republican
bills
in 43 states to suppress the vote so
yeah sure you can take the view that
it's quite simple
and it's democrats want more people to
vote so they win republicans want fewer
people to vote so they win
one of those perspectives happens to be
in line with the foundation of this
country now
as a very practical matter in the
immediate republicans
have a particularly pressing reason to
oppose hr1
which is that they're winning the house
back in 2022
could depend on whether something like
hr1 passes or doesn't pass
and we'll talk more about that in the
future that's
hr1 let's now talk about covid stimulus
one of our sponsors is monk pack
it's tough to get excited about most
granola bars
they have a lot of carbs they don't
taste that great
they don't really satisfy your cravings
but monk pack has something totally
different monk pack
keto granola bars are sweet and
delicious
with a soft and chewy texture
only 140 calories one gram of sugar
and only two to three net carbs which
make them work
perfectly for the keto or low carb
lifestyles
they come in excellent flavors like
coconut cocoa chip
honey nut blueberry almond vanilla
that's my new favorite
i love these because you can just grab
them anytime maybe it's a quick
breakfast an afternoon snack when you're
busy
forget the dry bland granola bars you've
had in the past
try out monk pack keto granola bars
if you don't love them like i do they'll
give you all of your money back
you'll get twenty percent off when you
go to monkpack.com and use the coupon
code
pacman the link is underneath this video